les chefs-d'oeuvre disait george sand ne
sont jamais que des tentatives heureuse
à en croire la romancière qui a tant
écrit sur le berry c'est ici que richard
coeur de lion aurait scellé la paix avec
philippe auguste dans ce château au
panorama de 50 kilomètres sur la vallée
noire aux 12 exceptionnel toujours en
état mais le reste est frappée désormais
d'un arrêté de péril imminent
interdiction d'entrée les fissures sont
si large par endroits qu'on y passe le
bras d'où l'intérêt du loto du
patrimoine je pense que berne a été
sensible au fait de cet état de péril
c'est à dire qu'il y avait vraiment un
risque d'effondrement majeur il a été
certainement sensible aussi à l'histoire
car ce donjon c'est l'un des plus
anciens la de notre département
la fondation du patrimoine alou 211 1000
euros au château c'est la moitié de la
somme nécessaire pour les seuls travaux
d'urgence des travaux d'étayage déjà en
cours
le reste n'est pas encore chiffré entre
un pignon qui s'affaisse et des remblais
instables sous les fondations mais avec
l'aide de la drac la direction des
affaires culturelles
l'idée est d'ouvrir d'ici cinq ans on
prévoira pendant l'été 20 printemps été
automne des journées à thèmes qui
peuvent être des journées historique
médiéval qui peuvent être des journées
culturelles avec concert avec théâtre on
peut avoir des feux d'artifice on peut
avoir des
des sons et lumières faire revivre le
village aussi c'est tout ce dont rêvait
le restaurant d'à côté même pour nous on
avait beaucoup de clients qui disait
mais on pourrait pas à visiter
on pourrait pas ben désolé vous pouvez
voir de l'extérieur mais vous pouvez pas
faire grand chose de plus
donc c'est vrai que c'est une super
nouvelle si ça permet effectivement de
pouvoir un petit peu ouvrir les grilles
que les gens puissent se balader visiter
le jardin c'est cela qu'a gagné le berry
au loto du travail aujourd'hui de la
culture demain pour les riverains